l'évidence est là l'inflation galope
jusqu'à 7% d'ici la fin de l'année
tandis que le pouvoir d'achat des
français recule de 2,9 pour cent sur les
premiers trimestres l'évidence c'est que
les français les moins aisés souffre
bientôt ce n'est plus de pouvoir d'achat
qu'il faudra parler mais de pouvoir de
vivre l'évidence c'est qu'en 2021 les
entreprises du cac 40 ont réalisé 174
milliards d'euros de bénéfices explosant
le record de 2007 200 milliards 80
milliards de dividendes ont été reversés
aux actionnaires ces gens qui profitent
du travail des autres et les salaires
des patrons ont augmenté de 23%
l'occasion d'une petite valse du en même
temps emmanuel macron dénoncé au dernier
g7 les profiteurs de guerre et les
spéculateurs mais temporise et dès le 14
juillet il y aurait une contribution
certes mais pas dans la démagogie vous
même madame la première ministre
adoptiez l'art du contretemps s'il y a
des gens qui tirent des profits de la
crise on souhaiterait que ça puisse
bénéficier à tout le monde et vous
précisiez que nous n'étions pas dans la
situation de nos voisins qui ont
instauré une taxe sur les super-profits
super profits le mot est lâché dans le
domaine énergétique et du transport
maritime en particulier total plus de 15
milliards en 2000 21 5 milliards au
premier trimestre 2010 22 la cma-cgm a
vu son bénéfice multiplié par dix en
2021 nous ne leur demandons pas une
aumône de 20 centimes ou une remise de
250 euros par transport de conteneurs
nous exigeons une contribution par
l'impôt qui pour autant qu'ils soient
justes est un pilier de la république ce
n'est pas au conseil d'administration de
décider de la participation des
entreprises à l'effort national mais au
parlement en l'inscrivant dans la loi en
toute transparence c'est une question de
démocratie
madame la première ministre gouvernement
va-t-il déposé dans le projet de loi de
finances rectificative un amendement
pour taxer les super profits ou à minima
soutenir les amendements parlementaires
y compris de vos amis qui vont aussi en
ce sens
[Musique]